[Music playing]
I have played video games all my life
This is my favorite hobby
I learned how to program computers
And then in 2001
We established our first video game company
For mobile phones in Spain and we call it Microjocs
In 2013, my company purchased a large studio
I decided with some friends
To do something different
Something new we set up Omnidrone
"Titan Brawl" is a real-time strategy game
They are MOBA
No game on a huge online battlefield
But specifically designed for mobile devices
The game has become as it is today
Thanks to the demo program
We made a lot of changes
Through learning from the community of players
Since we launched the game for experimental use
The number of installations reached more than two million
Install on Android devices
We started the activity in the experimental use program
When he was in his infancy
The difference between the trial use program
The traditional release is that users
They give their comments to the team effectively
So in addition to checking the standards that you have
You are also providing possible solutions
Ultimately the game is designed by the players
Although there are no evaluations
We got the players comments and it was very good
Experimental use was a great opportunity
For an independent and developer programmer
It was very basic for us in Omnidrone
When we started the demo use program
We applied it at different stages
So the idea was at first
Focus on game interaction
And when we dealt with this aspect
We focused on the retention rate in the game
Finally, we focused on monetization
With the aim of providing a high value product in the market
Thanks to the experimental use we were able
Increased retention rate of 41%
Level of interaction by 50%
Increase income by 20%
Since the start of the program
And even launch the game around the world
I am happy with my work
In the video game industry
It has been my dream since I was a child
It is really exciting that it is through Omnidrone
We have a real chance
To formulate and form a new era of video games.
[Sneezing and swish sounds]